- What's up, Believe Nation?
So, I'm curious to figure
out which YouTube channels
do you guys watch daily?
(whooshing)
So, I got an alert saying
that I was in a video
from one of my fans,
and I went to go check out the video,
and it's a cool video.
It's about her entire morning routine,
and we'll link it up below
so you guys can check it out,
but I wanted to include one section of it,
where she included my
channel and another person's
on her daily list of
things that she checks out.
- First thing I do is taking my iPad
and checking on my YouTube subscriptions
and see the new videos so that I can watch
motivational videos when I
get ready in the morning.
One essential part of my morning routine
is Evan Carmichael's channel
because of the motivational
content he puts out,
and for lifestyle things, I
love to follow Kandi Nicholson.
I will link both channels below.
- So, I'm curious for you guys,
what YouTube channels do
you watch on a daily basis?
Like you can't live, well
I guess you could live,
but you know, you don't want
to live without that channel
on a regular basis.
What is it that you're consuming?
I think of it, for me, on a daily basis,
a daily basis, the only
channel that I watch
on a daily basis is my own.
If I'm looking consistent
basis, like at least weekly,
I'm looking at Gary Veynerchuk,
I'm looking at Lewis Howes,
I'm looking at, recently, Breakfast Club,
some of their interviews are interesting,
and then some League of Legends channels,
but I think, from a
business entrepreneur angle,
that's it.
Mine, Gary V., Lewis
Howes, and Breakfast Club,
and I'm curious for you guys,
who are you watching?
What are you watching, first, daily,
most important, daily?
What YouTube channel do
you watch every single day,
and then, if you don't
have any, then every week?
At least you're watching
one video per week.
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out,
learn more about you,
what you're watching,
and also, maybe discover
some channels for myself
that I haven't heard of before,
so link that up.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
See you soon.
(whooshing)